[Music]
Luther beer Luther chocolate and Luther
liquor there's nothing you can't buy the
huge selection of anniversary products
is being sold mainly in specialty shops
like those own efforts Kramer brooken
you can also find this creation a Luther
Bible made of salami the most fitting
way to drink the beer that goes with it
is from these Luther mugs they're made
by hand in the workshop of efforts
Christopher is back a charitable
organization then there's this
high-calorie treat the Luther Bible in
chocolate as far as chocolate is
concerned if his portrait is on it it
sells especially well in every possible
variation this nougat inkwell is really
sweet in all the towns connected with
Luther the money is rolling in topping
the list of course is Wittenberg where
he posted his 95 theses naturally you
can also buy them as souvenirs
[Music]
you won't find the hammer a nail to go
with them but otherwise the range of
Luther products knows no bounds
[Music]
the reformer makes great pasta and of
course he loves to stand in the snow but
whether that really encourages people to
think of him or the Reformation remains
doubtful despite all the fun
[Music]